explain Germany I mean I can't you know
and if I were a better person maybe a
better Christian I'd feel badly for them
I don't
sorry they drove themselves into the
ditch at speed with this energy Venda
and they're going to waste a trillion
dollars or more and the result is be is
going to be economic ruination they're
deindustrializing they're facing not
only negative economic growth today
their biggest industrial firms are
saying we're going overseas a lot of
them are going to come to the US and I'm
Pro us but this is bad for Germany it's
bad for Europe and Germany is the
biggest economy in Europe so if Germany
declines it's going to have Ripple
effects throughout the continent but
they tied themselves to to Russian gas
and you can blame Angela Merkel for part
of this as well as some of the other
politicians for this energy Venda which
is just absolutely ruinous and they
can't build enough Renewables they've
had wind droughts last year that put
them on the edge of blackouts so these
ideas around hitching our economy solely
to these weather dependent Renewables
it's just Madness